Bro, bro.
How's everyone doing this morning?
You guys alright?
I'm alright.
I said, is everyone alright?
What a good way to start the morning, huh?
Oh my goodness.
It's very exciting.
So, obviously you all know why you're here today.
Yes?
Some of you?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Some of you guys know.
I don't know about all of you.
But, so today is a Q&A panel with a thief.
It's also secretly a tomato.
But, there are some ground rules.
Okay?
She's very kind and is fully allowing pictures and recording just like tomorrow.
Just don't disturb your neighbors.
Only ground rules you guys have.
Sound good?
Awesome.
Okay.
So, a little bit of a breakdown.
Because you have a couple of minutes to kill.
This is how it's just going to go down.
I am going to be down here.
And I, with our special guest's help, will pick a couple of people.
And, uh, they will get interviewed.
And, then we'll roll into the Q&A.
Okay?
Alright.
Okay.
Um, I don't know.
Are we ready to go?
No?
I see some cross arms.
So now I gotta kill some time up here.
Hmm, what am I gonna do?
How am I gonna do?
We got two light sticks.
Yes.
Excellent.
Oh!
There's so many.
Why did I not notice them?
Sure, yeah.
Give me a light stick.
Woo, yay!
It's like a mini lightsaber.
Oh, this is too much power.
I should not have this much power in the morning.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Well, I think we, uh...
Oh, it got real quiet real fast.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, wow.
Oh, people are waving with their lights.
Yay!
So, uh, who was here for the event?
Yesterday.
Is there anybody who's a first time attendee for AR this year?
In here?
Oh!
Oh, wow.
There's a lot of you.
Welcome.
Good morning.
Oh, by the way, my name's McKee.
Hello.
Hello, new people.
Yes.
Oh, thank you, Shark Man.
I remember you from yesterday.
So much hype.
Oh, you did!
Oh, you got the water bottle!
Yes!
Uh, by the way, uh, she is better than all of you at Rock, Paper, Scissors.
So, I mean, it's just, it's, it's a fact now.
The water bottle proves it.
I'm just saying.
Well, man, we got a lot of seats over here.
I see a couple people sitting in the far back.
There's so many seats over here.
You guys wanna come?
Bring your friends, you know?
I'm just saying.
There's a lot of seats.
Where'd you get the other light stick?
I have your light stick.
I only got two hands and I got a microphone.
Well, how?
I'm already dual wielding.
Oh, I can't do that.
How did you get another light stick?
How many do you have in that bag?
Be honest.
It's like a double Darth Maul over here.
You got three?
One hand?
Okay.
Okay, let's do that.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, well, let's get started over here.
I have the distinct privilege of obviously welcoming our special guest.
Like I said, a thief.
And I learned this morning she's also secretly a tomato.
Don't tell anybody.
I've been told not to tell anyone.
So you are all in it with me, okay?
Again, ground rules apply.
You're allowed to record.
You're allowed to take photos.
Just don't bother anybody else.
So without further ado, help me welcome...
Doki Man!
Apparently I have a talk show right now.
So as we all know in talk shows, I have to dance.
So like, I guess this is me dancing.
And because it's a talk show, look under your seats!
Because...
There's nothing.
So...
I can't believe someone has actually looked under your seats.
Oh my gosh!
You guys have been sitting here for like 15 minutes and you really think there's something under your seats now?
Like...
Oh my gosh!
I'm so excited to be here on the second day!
I'm very tired.
I had to wake up at 7.30 a.m.
I usually don't wake up this early in the morning.
So I'm just like...
Oh my god!
I was like 30 minutes late to the tech rehearsal too.
Like yeah, oh my gosh!
She has such an ego.
She's already late to like rehearsals.
Guys, my old PC setup is literally at my old place.
And like...
I have a very long commute to get there!
I was like...
Oh my...
Oh...
But Jokey, you make so much money now!
Why don't you just take Uber?
Because I literally just moved!
It's so expensive!
I'm not gonna fucking give Uber more of my money!
Like...
They're hurting me too much getting my Uber Eats money!
They don't need to get my Uber car money!
I do too!
Oh!
But yeah!
I'm really happy to be here!
The EMI talk show!
And like...
As like all talk shows have...
We have a little...
A little talk show set!
Where's my table?
Sorry, I'm very professional.
Where's my...
Here we go.
Here's my table.
Let me move over here.
Alright!
Since this is a talk show, I'm gonna be interviewing a special guest today.
And that special guest...
It is...
You guys!
I'm gonna interview...
I'm gonna interview some dragoons.
So you guys better be very special.
Who wants to get interviewed?
We're gonna do the lottery here!
I have some special set of questions for all of you guys.
Alright, raise your hand if you wanna get interviewed and my tech people will pick a lucky dragoon out there.
I don't know, I need to see some hands waving quite vigorously.
I don't know!
Where are we gonna go?
It's up to you!
Where are we going?
We gotta connect your flying up there!
No!
It's just waving over here!
You know what?
You're waving quite vigorously.
You don't wanna...
Step up, step up!
Oh my god, really?
Two hands and...
Alright.
Alright, wait, wait.
Before you go...
Before you say anything, give me a sec.
I gotta set something up here.
Before you give me...
Before you get interviewed, give me a sec.
Alright!
Don't cox yourself!
Wait, sit closer to the mic!
I can't hear you!
Felix Argyle from ReZero.
Alright, Felix.
Alright, here.
Welcome to the Doki Bird Talk Show!
Alright, first question!
Who's your Oshii?
Uh, Sakura Miko.
Okay, get the...
I'm gonna interview the next person.
Get him out.
Get this person out.
I'm gonna...
Sit down.
Sit down your seat right now.
You're out.
Alright, who wants to get interviewed?
That was the wrong answer.
Alright!
Pick the next person!
Oh my god, I can't wait!
Alright, yeah, yeah.
Come on up.
I can't wait to interview my very first guest, guys!
I'm letting you know he had chocolate milk in his hand and he put it down.
Just for this.
Oh, yeah.
I just had breakfast.
I'm sorry.
I had to hang out today and I'm like, what's going on?
Alright!
What's your name, sir?
What's your name?
Uh, Christopher.
Christopher!
Okay.
Alright, Christopher.
You were my first guest today at the Doki Bird Talk Show!
Alright, first question, Christopher.
Doki Bird.
Who's your Oshii?
Yeah!
I heard she's a really great entertainer.
Oh, good answer!
Good answer!
As my first guest, that has been the best answer of today!
Bye!
So!
What do you like about Doki Bird?
Uh...
Everything.
Everything?
Gotta be specific!
What exactly?
What makes Doki Bird so special?
Doki Bird.
Alright, get this person out of here.
Move it!
Get out of here!
Shhh!
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
I got this.
Someone's chair-ass answer you can give me.
Who's, uh...
What is this?
What are you looking at?
Are you showing me a receipt?
That's too bad.
Showing me a merch receipt?
That's a good...
Come up with Mr. Sam.
You know what?
Alright, alright.
Whoever that person is.
Here we go, here we go.
Alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, that microphone is a little bit too tall for you.
I got it, I got it.
Don't worry, alright.
We're gonna moralize that forever, I guess.
Alright, hello!
What's your name?
My very first guest of today!
I'm a...
I'm a rodent.
Alright, alright, alright.
Who's your Oshi?
Doki Bird.
Oh, that's great to hear!
Great answer!
I can't believe
you like about Doki Bird.
Well, besides everything, just like the high energy, the goofy attitude...
The...
Mm-hmm.
Keep going?
Can I say stop?
Like...
Keep going?
Is that really all you can say?
Oh, wait.
Did this get...
Really?
That's really it?
I...
This should be going on for like another five minutes!
Is that really it?
Please!
Okay, what?
Okay, alright.
I'll give you another chance.
As my first guest, I'm gonna give you another chance.
Alright, so...
What is your favorite moment from Doki Bird?
Uh...
The debut.
The debut?
Yeah!
What is your favorite part of the debut?
I would say the...
Um...
I'm blanking.
Alright, get him out, get him out.
Move it!
I wonder you're a Doki.
Get out of here.
It's already so massive.
Alright, where am I going here?
Where am I going here?
There is no hesitation.
Pika Doki!
I saw some Doki's here!
Pika...
Only a Doki can ask your Doki question.
You know what?
There's one right here in the front.
There's another big one right here in the front.
Come on up, bud.
Oh my god, is that...
Isn't that a Doki?
Alright, give me a sec.
Oh my god, hello Doki.
It's great to see you again, Doki.
Yeah, it's great to see you again, Doki.
Alright, only...
You know what?
Only a Doki can answer some Doki questions.
Alright.
Okay.
As a fellow Doki, who's your favorite Doki?
Favorite Doki?
Is Doki.
Your favorite Doki bird is Doki?
Yeah.
What do you mean by that?
There's so many Doki's in the Doki-verse.
What do you mean by Doki?
I think the only correct Doki is Dad.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
You've been kicked out of the Doki-verse.
I'm sorry, we do not own you anymore.
Valid.
I stand by my answer.
We do not own this Doki anymore.
This Doki has been banished from the Doki-verse.
I'm just saying in a good flow.
Okay, here we go.
Pick another Doki.
Clearly.
There's a lot over here.
There's so many over here.
Okay, come on up.
Right here, right here.
Yes, you.
Come on up.
That's my first and last Doki guest here.
Clearly, you have all failed me.
Don't worry, don't worry.
It's redemption time.
No pressure.
I don't know where you're getting all these Doki's, but clearly, there's a reason why I'm here as a guest and you're not Doki.
Alright, hello Doki.
Hello.
Alright, Doki.
Well, as my first guest, who's your favorite Doki?
Doki Bird.
Oh, Doki Bird.
But specifically which Doki Bird from the Doki-verse?
The Kroki.
The tomato.
Sorry, the show has been canceled.
We have decided to cancel the Doki Bird talk show because of creative differences with the team.
Now, sadly, sadly, Doki Bird talk show has been canceled now.
Oh.
This has now been rebranded as the Doki Bird Q&A.
Wow, guys.
You guys just wasted $5 million of budget on the Doki Bird talk show.
We were going to have musical guests from like, I don't know, Pitbull was going to show up and do his thing.
I can't believe it.
You guys got it canceled.
We could have had it all, Jack.
We could have had it all, Dragoo.
Remember, it was your fault.
Well then, since the Doki Bird talk show has been canceled, I guess I'll take a Q&A now.
The budget has lessened to like $5, so now it's Q&A time.
Okay.
I think it's my time again.
I get to pick somebody to come up, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get to pick somebody to come up.
Oh, you can, you can come up.
Yes, there we go.
Oh, no.
Alright, so Doki.
Yeah?
Are you and Peter still together?
Bro, the poor man.
Honestly, I'm so surprised that shit went viral.
And then, it's like, what do you do when you go viral?
Like, I don't know.
I was like, I have a convention to do.
I can't be doing anything.
You know, that video has like, 6 million views now?
6.4.
6.4?
That poor man.
It, like, got so big that I heard that people were posting it on Facebook.
That's when you know he's fucked because he's posting it on Facebook.
You can't even see the GIF.
Like, you can even find the GIF of my reaction on Twitter GIFs, which is really crazy to think about.
And then, like, it got translated in so many different languages.
So, like, people in different countries know about this poor man getting fumbling.
Like, not even to 3K people now.
It's to, like, millions of people.
But to be fair, like, why don't...
Console has voice chat.
Has Discord.
Why would you say this randomly in a public voice chat?
I still don't understand.
I just...
If he had to get it out in an Apex play...
Apex up, like, quick play match, then he never had a chance in the first place.
He's already suffering enough.
You don't have to do that to him.
I mean, we all feel bad for that guy.
Oh, my God.
That poor guy.
I hope he one day finds his Apex e-girl.
Oh, my God.
I hope he finds one.
I hope one day.
You know, after, like...
After what happened to him, like...
It's important character development.
That's true.
I mean, like...
Like, the fact that, like, he...
That team coincidentally cued into me and not knowing that I'm a streamer.
And then end up saying all of that stuff.
Being like, oh...
At least, like...
At least the only fumble...
I saw...
The only person that saw that fumble was this random person on our team.
Not knowing that she's a streamer.
Oh, man.
He doesn't know.
I hope he never knows.
He's gonna fight eventually.
Who knows?
I will be very surprised...
Well, actually, no, no.
I...
I'm just surprised that no one has...
Like, none of those people have acknowledged the clip yet.
Like, I don't think I've seen, like, the actual people in that...
in that clip acknowledging that it's them.
So, like...
Well, two members are console players.
I don't think they even have social media.
Oh!
I didn't say that.
You were thinking it.
Those were...
Those are supposed to be your inside thoughts.
This is why...
I'm a streamer, because I keep my inside thoughts to myself.
Alright.
That's a good question.
I hope that...
One day...
I hope that Saul one day finds his dream girl.
That's not taken by Petey.
Well, speaking of finding...
I gotta find somebody else.
Let's see.
Where am I going?
I don't know.
I feel like I got a piece of love back here.
But I don't know.
They don't seem very exciting.
So, maybe I'll hook over here.
Oh, that's...
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Do you have a stop sign?
What the hell?
I don't know.
That's a stop sign.
Where did you get...
Where did you get that from?
That was my question.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where am I looking here?
Oh, there's a lot of hype over here.
Sure.
Okay.
Come on up.
Yeah!
Wow!
He's, uh...
He's ready.
Come on up.
Look at you.
He had the whole...
Whole section going for him.
Oh, then it might be a really good question.
Or a really, really dumb question.
Really bad question.
It could be a really bad question.
What is that?
Is that Nutella?
We're not doing it.
Is that ketchup?
What is that?
It's ketchup.
Oh, I...
Okay.
What are you gonna do with this ketchup bottle?
When are we getting renamed to Nesticles?
If not, I'm burning you into ketchup.
This will be you.
This was a threat?
This was a picture, though.
That's crazy.
Did you just eat ketchup when I turned around?
Keep
doing it.
Keep doing it.
Come on.
Hold this.
Keep doing it.
Guys, are we bad people?
Oh, shit.
That's half the bottle.
Oh, my God.
Alright, now you can go sit back in your chair now.
I don't want an answer.
That's too bad.
It's a threat.
This was...
Where am I going?
Alright?
That was a nice public humiliation drag game.
I'm glad we all have thought the same thing together.
What is it?
It's a toe kick in the head of the flag.
Guys, I got Tim Hortons ice caps today.
But like...
Okay, we shouldn't cheer for that because it's Tim Hortons.
We all know their coffee is not the best.
I don't know why you cheer for Tim Hortons.
It wasn't working.
Now I gotta pick somebody else here.
Okay?
Someone who's not gonna threaten anybody.
Oh, my gosh.
You got a shirt on?
Get over here.
No threats.
Is that the requirement?
You got a shirt on?
Like, I hope that everybody has a shirt on.
Hey, listen.
Alright, not all this is even high standards.
Alright?
That's all I'm saying.
I hope everybody has a shirt on.
Don't free the nipple.
Sorry, I'm just a bit nervous.
Don't worry, man.
You have a shirt on.
That's okay.
Thank you.
Not really a question, but like...
So I've...
Shit.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't smirk on the mic.
We're all up to you, but no question.
Okay, so last year there was a VTuber who came to Vancouver.
And, um, so you might know, like, there's, there's a tradition, right?
We just grab some onion rings and...
What's the question?
Oh!
What?
It's not even...
It's not even a question!
I shouldn't, I shouldn't...
I shouldn't have picked the guy with the shirt.
I know.
Alright, someone...
Okay, hold on.
I don't have the very first...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should ask them what they want to ask first before you get asked.
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe, but wait, hold on, what do you want to ask?
Don't worry, I'll help you a good job.
Please be a good question.
So, the person I'm sitting beside also had this question.
English or Spanish?
I ain't afraid.
Come on!
I have a serious question.
Okay.
For people that want to become VTubers, what would your advice be?
Finally...
Um...
Not be mental...
Okay.
The joke answer is not be mentally well, but the real...
The real...
We're not...
Okay.
Right now.
But, like, the real answer is, um, if you want to get started as a VTuber, gotta do it as a hobby.
Do not go full in.
Because, like, obviously, I've said it before, but, like, VTubing to making content creation in general, it's, like, 99% luck, in my opinion.
Um, because it's basically, like, you have to get your big break.
So, um, and it's very, very hard to make it when the market itself is, like, super saturated.
So, you gotta be, like, unique in a way.
And you gotta be...
Yeah, you can't be...
And you can't be an introvert as a content creator.
Because...
I mean, you can, but it's gonna be a lot harder for you.
So, you gotta be very open to be social to people, and, like, open to, like, network and collaborate with others.
And, um, I would highly suggest starting out on Twitch, even though I'm a YouTube streamer.
Um, because I already have an established fanbase, so it's easier to be on YouTube.
And discoverability for streaming is very easy on Twitch.
But discoverability on YouTube is not, because where the fuck do I find streams on YouTube?
Like, you know what?
You have to...
I just, like, how do I find new people on YouTube?
It's so difficult.
Um, but I would suggest, like, um, abusing shorts on YouTube, or short-form content.
Because, like, TikTok is about to be gone in America.
So...
TikTok is gonna be banned in the United States of America.
Uh, because, oh, they're gathering our data.
But who...
But everybody's gathering our data, so who cares?
Anyway, uh, because of that, YouTube's like, ooh, TikTok's gonna be gone.
I'm gonna be the next TikTok.
So they're hard...
They're heavy pushing short-form content now.
That's why everybody is spamming shorts and, like, short streams.
So, like, I would highly suggest just spamming shorts and stuff from your streams on YouTube, and putting, like, highlights and stuff on YouTube, but then fully streaming on Twitch.
But yes, do it as a hobby, and then when it starts being more sustainable, you can look into doing it as, like, a full-time thing.
Like, even a lot of...
Even a lot of, like, um, big streamers, they don't quit their job, like, their main job, until, like, they know it's, like, said, said type film.
So, because I know some YouTubers that actually still have, like, a second job.
So, like, uh, because this is, like, the hobby of theirs, or, like, it's not, like, something that they think they could do for a long time, because they're not fully sure yet.
So, yeah, just do it as a hobby first, and then when you think it's a sure-sure deal, then full-time.
Because this is, for me, I don't have a second job.
So I'm fucked if something happens to me.
But that's okay.
Don't do what I do, son.
Yeah, that's an actual good question!
Thank you so much.
I wish you were the first person I asked.
Everyone buy her membership.
Yes.
Buy my merch, too.
All right.
Okay, first, first, first thing this person said is I have a good question.
I swear to God.
Get up there.
You know, like, one out of ten?
That's not very good statistically-wise.
I'm redoing that one.
Oh, hold on.
Still.
Oh, no, no, no.
Okay, who's got a good question?
Who's got a good question?
Okay, hold on.
Let me, let me check.
Yeah, there's so much pressure on you.
I don't know.
But is that one good question?
Could be a fluke.
This is a good question.
All right, all right.
This is actually a good question.
How good is it?
Let's see.
I don't know.
No pressure or anything.
I mean, to be fair, there were a lot of bad questions before you, so, like, you literally could not do worse.
I know I'm good because you told us to ask this.
Okay.
Yes.
So I hear that there are a couple of con-exclusive FOMO stories that you have heard.
Oh!
The FOMO story.
I know, like, there's actually some Dragoons that have went to every convention, or, like, almost every convention that have heard you sending the story over and over, because they thought, I think they, I think some of them thought that, like, that story would be different every convention,
but it's the same story.
So I'm very sorry to some of my Dragoons that have actually thought I'm gonna be, like, giving different stories every convention.
But I appreciate it.
I appreciate you guys coming here.
Alright.
So the reason why I don't tell this story on YouTube or on stream, like, it doesn't matter if it's on Twitch or anything, is that I'm very worried, I'm gonna say a word in the story, and then YouTube or Twitch is gonna flag it.
So, basically, a long time ago, a very dark past of mine.
I used to be a fan of Italia.
It was a very dark time.
It was an incredibly dark time of mine.
Because I wasn't into Italia because I loved history.
There was another reason why people liked Italia.
Those who don't know what Italia is, it's like the personification of countries as pretty boys, and sometimes pretty girls, but mostly pretty handsome boys.
So, my favorite character was Prussia.
And I just really liked his personality.
And also, like, other stuff.
But, like, the other stuff as in, like, I really liked it when he shipped with, like, you know, other countries.
I told you, it was a very dark time.
It was a very, very dark time.
So, because my favorite character was Prussia, oh my god, I just realized his mascot was a bird, too.
Oh my god, it's a full circle.
I just realized it's a yellow bird.
Okay, anyway.
One day, on Halloween, I decided to cosplay Prussia on Halloween at my school.
And so, like, I had everything.
Like, the wig, the outfit, the whole entire cosplay.
Including the Iron Cross.
So, because it was very accurate.
So, I went to school as the Prussia cosplay.
And then a teacher dragged me to the corner when they saw my outfit.
And was like, are you a Nazi?
And I was like, no.
I was playing as an anime character.
It's Prussia from Italia.
And obviously, it's some old guy.
Old guy who's a math teacher.
He doesn't know what the fuck is Prussia.
I mean, he knows what Prussia is.
But he's like, what the fuck?
You're a person.
Like, he doesn't know.
Italia?
So, I got in a little trouble.
Because, yeah, people thought I was a Nazi.
So, it was really bad.
And that's why I don't tell this story on stream.
Because I'm worried if I say Nazi, YouTube's gonna be like, what the fuck, she's a Nazi.
And I'm like, I don't want that to happen.
Also, people might clip me on a contest and be like, Toki cosplayed as Prussia?
Oh my god.
She's a Nazi.
I don't want it to get clipped like that.
So...
This is why this is only exclusive to conventions.
If it makes you feel any better, there was a kid at my school who actually dressed as a Nazi for Halloween.
Ohhhh!
I don't even know what to say.
Because I have no excuse.
It was...
Is that...
Ice caps?
Nice.
Yeah, it's a good ice cap.
Literally the only good thing they make.
Wait, I...
No questions.
The only bad question and you rejected it.
I didn't reject it.
They rejected it.
Okay, okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let me see.
Who do you think has a good question?
I don't know.
Alright, that guy...
That guy that's waving his sticks like it's on fire.
Which one?
There's so many over here.
There's multiple?
That one guy that I see on the camera.
Yeah, yeah, that guy.
Okay, alright, come up here.
Let me hear your question real quick.
Alright, if it's a really bad question, just let him say it.
But if it's a really, really bad question, don't let him say it.
I'll trust your judgment.
First mistake.
He doesn't have a question for it, he was just excited.
I'm gonna wave my sticks, it's not like he's gonna pick me or anything.
You'll take the bullet?
Alright, that's a good question.
That's a good question.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Welcome, welcome up to this person.
Hey!
Slowly making his way over the bike.
I'm not gonna run.
What's good?
I'm good?
Is that your question?
No, that's... that's a statement, but...
What made you fall in love with MeTuber?
Oh... that is a good question.
Okay, I won't say in love.
Okay, um, I think it's mostly because, like, you know, with a skin suit, like, you know, you can just put it on and then just, like, I can get up and put on my skin suit and then go live and all that stuff.
So, like, that's the best part.
Like, um, you don't need to prep for anything or any way.
You just wake up.
It's stream time.
And, like, also, like, um, because, like, before then, before then, I didn't stream with, like, anything.
It was just gameplay-wise.
So, like, when VT being first, like, became a thing, I was, like, really interested in it.
And this was before, I talked about this before, but, like, this was before Hollow EN even debuted.
So, like, it was, like, really new in the western side.
Um, so, and I don't know if you guys know this, but back in the days, a long time in 2019 to 2020, um, nobody used 2D.
Like, not nobody, but, like, it was so rare.
It was, like, 2D was considered the, the, the, um, too expensive.
So, people would be using 3D instead for VTubing.
Like, with Vroid and, uh, and, like, uh, Lupit and all that stuff.
And it was, like, 3D was the cheaper alternative, which was crazy to think back then.
Because now people are, like, we gotta work hard to get 3D.
But back then, it was, like, 3D is the cheapest alternative to 2D.
And, um, I remember, like, getting into, like, reading about 3D stuff and thinking about, like, oh, I really love how expressive you can be in 3D.
And, like, talking to your viewers and everything.
And I thought it was, like, such a cool idea.
And how you could, like, change outfits, like, by changing skin suits and ripping your skin off and then putting on different skin on.
Um, and I thought that was so cool.
And honestly, like, I felt like it was very interactive, too, for fans.
And, um, it's also, like, technology, too.
So, like, it's a growing market.
And it's gonna keep getting better and better and better.
But when you're a fleshy, how else can you get better?
You're, you're just flesh.
Like...
Like, oh, they're gonna have, like, a stronger camera for your fleshy self that's gonna see all your pores?
Like, no, fuck that shit.
Like, there's no improvement to flesh.
Uh-huh.
But there's gonna be improvement to technology.
To, like, um, to, like, V-tubing.
Every, every year there's gonna be some unique thing, unique new meta, unique trend that's gonna be in V-tubing.
Cause it's all 2D slash 3D.
While fleshies have nothing.
So that's why I like V-tubing.
Don't worry!
But, yeah, that's why I fell in love with V-tubing.
I love the interactiveness of it.
And how expressive you can be.
Thank you.
Yeah!
I gotta vet your question first.
Hold on.
Hands are shaking and there's a list.
There's a list?
There's a list.
You only get one on the list.
You only got one on the list!
Oh, he's like, oh no, what?
I thought I could ask 20.
Damn, he's, he's thinking real hard.
Alright, okay, alright.
One of the, better be that one.
Alright, Mr. Shaky Hands.
Hello, it's me again.
Hello, hello!
Okay, out of all of your friends, which one would you think would survive on an island?
Bro, all of my friends are V-tubers.
None of them are from this island.
Okay, not just V-tubers, but also people, the flesh-shares who are on.
I would say none of them, because they're all terminally online.
So like...
Like, I know I won't survive.
Like, I'm thinking, I was like, do any of them have like, actual survival skills?
And I'm like, no, we'd all die, because we have no, like, we have no technology.
I guess like...
Not, okay, I'm thinking.
No, they'll all die.
We're all, we're all, like, content creators.
You think we have skin-up survival skills?
Like...
You know what I mean?
Bro, bro, I don't- I haven't- I haven't capped in like, since the- since my horror stories of capping.
And that was so long ago.
That's why I was like, in the- in ninth grade.
But yes, that's my answer.
We would all die if we were stranded.
So please, please make sure we don't get stranded in this- in an island.
Okay, I gotta go now.
Apparently I can't ask multiple questions.
Only one question.
Yes.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
I'll take it here as well.
Start headbanging.
Let me vet your question.
Get over here.
Oh, there's a door.
Alright, okay.
I was gonna say, that seems like a long question.
It's actually pretty short, you know.
I get a little bit of trippy.
Hi.
Hello.
Who is your Oshii?
Who is my Oshii?
Doki Bird.
I mean, I literally have a shrine of Doki, so like, who else could it be?
But if you're asking non-VTubers, then it will be Daft Punk.
I hope Daft Punk...
I'm still so sad that he retired.
I'm still so sad.
Which Doki?
Which Doki is my favorite?
The one that's a guest at Annie Revo right now.
The one that gets all the special privileges compared to the other Doki's.
Alright, I got somebody.
I got somebody with a good question.
Go for it.
Hello!
Oh my god, he has a shirt on too!
Yeah!
They don't wear Doki shirts, they're technically naked.
Alright, my question is, as a future winner of Twitch Rivals, how did you do it?
Oh, future winner of Twitch Rivals!
Wow!
Wow, you're gonna be so disappointed right here.
How did I did it?
How did I do it?
Well, I will assume, I will assume you were watching the wrong stream.
That's how I did it.
As for those who don't know, I have a Twitch stream for Twitch Rivals, that was great, Apex Legends, at like 2 p.m.
So, like, I don't know, take your phone out and watch it.
And don't listen to whatever this guy is saying, because, like, there's no way I'm winning that.
But, like, I'll be there for, like, emotional support, I guess.
Thank you for the question.
Okay, I got another good question.
It's from the back.
Here we go.
Oh, the bad questions.
The loners out there.
Okay.
We're taking a long, slow, long...
Oh, there's a camera.
Oh, no.
I'm getting out of here.
Goodbye.
Enjoy.
Good luck.
No, no, you go.
The microphone's right in front of you.
I didn't even know that.
What do you mean don't know?
There's a camera at the microphone.
What's up, Goki?
Hello.
Okay, I have a question for you.
Yeah?
So, uh, what's your favorite nostalgic thing from the 2000s, since you're really into the 2000s stuff?
In the 2000s.
Is it 2000s to 2010?
2000s.
Okay, what's the...
Let's say the first decade.
The 2000s.
Like, what is it?
Like, 2000s to 2010?
Like, or 2000s, 2000s.
Like, 2000s.
2000s to 2000s.
Like, Y2K, 2000.
Yeah, why don't you think, you know, like, emo bands, or like, Neopets, or stuff like that.
Or even, like, only 2000s.
Oh, wait, Neopets is 2000s?
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Wait, give me a sec.
Me and me both.
Give me a sec.
No, Neopets can't be 2000s.
You can't do this to me.
Yeah.
What?
Okay, 2000s, okay.
The 2000s was for, like, college kids, not for me.
Yeah, for Neopets.
Oh my god.
What was my favorite thing from the 2000s?
Oh!
Okay, we're going, like, super nostalgic, nostalgic.
Does anyone...
Okay, sorry for the Zoomers out there.
But, like, does anyone remember those, like, little robot dogs?
Oh my god.
That does, like...
That's...
Now that's 2000.
Oh!
The little robot dogs or something?
Yes!
Yeah, those robot dogs.
And then, like, they have, like, floppy ears and stuff, and you give them those little bones.
They were, like, the cuter versions of Furbies.
Um, I had a Furby, but I think I was, like, way too young for a Furby, because I broke the Furby.
I, like, ripped...
Why?
This is not sociopathic behavior, by the way.
Like...
How did you break a Furby?
I, like, ripped the fur off of Furby.
But, like, that's not sociopathic, by the way.
Like...
I...
I just remember I broke the Furby, and I was always curious.
I was, like, ooh, why is he always blinking?
So I, like, peeled...
Like, not peeled, but I, like, forced open his eyes.
Oh my god.
So then, like, I could feel it.
The eyes start...
This is not sociopathic, by the way.
I was just a...
I was just a really curious child.
So, like, I would, like, I liked feeling it forced, trying to close his eyes, but it can't, because I'm, like, holding his eyes open and stuff.
And then the Furby broke, because it couldn't close its eyes anymore.
And then someone's Fur was, like, ripped... almost, like, you know, ripped off.
Because I was very curious to how it worked and everything.
And I turned out okay, by the way.
I turned out okay.
You're a beautiful girl!
How are you all out?
That's messed up.
But yes, um...
Okay, but, like, they're Furbies.
Like, they're so fucking weird.
Like, they're so...
Are you using a Doki Furby, then?
Yup.
Oh god, no.
God, it's... that's so ugly.
I don't know if people think Furbies are cute.
They're so...
They're... they're... they're... they look like serial killers.
Like, we all watched the... the Furby dog.
Like, y'all, that shit was scary.
Like...
Alright, but yes, good question.
Good question.
You need to sit back now.
I got another one from the back!
Whoa!
The back is getting some love right now!
Yeah, I mean, they're sitting back there all by themselves.
Like...
I mean, that's a choice, so...
So we know a VTuber model is really important for a VTuber.
I wanted to ask...
In your experience, what's it like commissioning a model from, like, the design and concept all the way to that feeling of wearing it for the first time?
Hmm, so, skin suit related question.
Well, um...
Well...
It was definitely very difficult design-wise, because it's like...
I was very...
Because I was like, do I go stick with the original four-plus-year-old design?
Or, like, go with something new?
That felt more like me.
Because, like I said before, Retro Joki wasn't really...
Like...
Retro Joki had a personality before I took over her.
Um...
And then, like, I par...
Like, as a parasite, I basically controlled Retro Joki and made it into me.
So she was, like, somebody else before she became me.
And then, uh...
So, like, Retro Joki wasn't really, like, fit...
I never really thought that Retro Joki, like, fit me a hundred percent, personality-wise.
So, like, I wanted to make something that was more me.
As, like, in terms of, like, what I play.
And, like, how, like, I conduct myself and everything.
So it was a very tough process.
I, like, as you guys saw in the, um...
2.0 review... reveal.
Um...
We went through a lot of designs before we settled in.
Like, at one point, I looked like Shibuya HAL.
And, uh...
So we went through a lot of iteration.
And it...
Right until, like, I debuted 2.0, as in the one you see right now, I was scared.
I was like, what if they don't like it?
Oh my god, that's good.
That's the worst part.
I was like, oh my god.
Because it was a whole redesign.
It was a whole new brand.
Like, went from theme to bounty hunter.
What a job.
Like, where's the connection between those two?
Uh...
So...
It was definitely...
It took months to figure it out.
I really appreciate my mom to be, like, to put up with that.
Because, like, obviously, they're very busy.
Like, I'm not their only client.
So...
So, like, at one point...
I don't know...
I don't think I've said this before.
But, like, in the very beginning, they were like, look, if we can't, like, settle on a design though...
Like, I don't know.
I don't know, Doki.
Like, I don't know if we could keep working if you can't even settle on a design.
Because I have a lot of clients and I'm like, okay, I gotta make this work.
So, it's just...
It takes a lot.
Because it's, like...
You have to figure out...
Also, like...
I don't know if this is a hot take or not.
But, like, I think...
I do not like it when skin suits are very complicated design-wise.
Because I feel like keeping it simple is the best because it's the most memorable.
At best, like, if you...
If you have, like, a good silhouette and, like, memorable, like, design aspects...
That's fine.
I hate clutter.
I just don't like clutter on a design.
So...
Yeah.
Keeping it simple as always.
As long as it's memorable...
It can't be, like, too simple where you're just, like...
Default anime girl with cat ears number 254.
Like, it can't be that simple.
But, like, more so of, like, have something memorable.
Like, a very memorable trait.
But don't over-clutter yourself, like, with everything.
Like, you...
Like a...
Like a sparkle dog.
Yes.
That's my answer.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah!
Okay.
I got somebody right over here.
Woo!
Oh!
They're going from the front!
I'm going to hit them off.
Oh, no!
They're running!
I don't think I'm going to fit enough for this.
Are you running?
No, I'm talking here.
Hello!
Oh, hi!
I think you might have to lean in a little closer.
Hi!
Would you like a chair?
Sure!
Wait, is that your question?
Alright, next question.
Next person.
As a connoisseur of the weird and unhinged, what is your favorite bit of skin suit lore?
Preferably the weirdest one.
My favorite skin suit lore?
The weirdest one?
But I'm not a freak.
Like, the weirdest one is that underneath all of this is that I'm a tomato.
How much weirder can that get?
Like, who else do you know is, like, an actual tomato?
I don't know if you guys know this, but I make up my lore as we go along.
Like, it comes up on the fly.
Like, I don't have, like, a hidden- I don't have, like, a notebook with, like, 200 pages of secret doki lore.
And literally, I just be like, that's funny.
That's my lore now.
If that's what you want us to think.
Sure.
Sure, you can go in there with your whole conspiracy theory.
I got a notebook!
Just like how we all know the Earth is flat.
That's hot.
Yeah, that's my answer.
Yeah, that's it.
Sorry, I'm not a freak.
Okay, I think- I think we're coming up to the end here, but I- Whoa!
Last final question.
Possibly about some announcements.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
What?
What are her announcements?
Oh, they're not very special, by the way.
Yeah, please don't go in- please don't go in with, like, super high hopes.
There's, like, not really special announcements.
What?
Okay, so I think what you wanted- what you asked is, uh, who would like a photo with everybody?
Yeah!
Wait, that was the last question?
We have, uh, we have our photographer extraordinaire, Kazuki somewhere.
Uh, so we'll be taking two photos.
Um, one where Kazuki's on the stage looking at the crowd, and then I'm forcing him to run all the way to the back of the room, and then take a photo with everybody and Goki.
Sound good?
All right, yeah!
Also, everybody, if you have any gifts or letters for Mint and I, I'll be accepting gifts for Mint as well.
Please just- I don't know, where do we- where do they leave them, tech guy?
I don't know.
Table is over there.
There are a couple of volunteers.
Okay, wherever the- wherever the emcee guy pointed to, if you have gifts and letters for Mint and I, please leave that at the table there.
We apologize that, uh, there was some miscommunication about yesterday.
Also, like, Mint and I were super frazzled, so, like, our routine was off because we were, like, we were trying to fix Mint's audio issue live.
So, like, I forgot to tell you guys about the gift situation, so, like, everybody was confused.
But we are accepting Mint's gifts now, and, like, just leave it at the table and then she'll get them as well.
And if you have- oh, wait, no, you're all gonna be there, so never mind.
I was just saying, if you can't leave it, could you make it to the panel?
And I'm like, no, they're all at the panel, where are you staying?
So, just leave it at the table.
And you'll get, like, 50 years of good luck because it's, like, a shrine thing.
I'll bless you with 50 years of good luck if you leave a gift or a letter.
Okay.
Worth it.
Kaz, do you want to come out?
Yes.
Everyone give a round of applause for Kazki!
Did you do it?
Free work!
Okay, Kaz, thank you.
Alright, you're running to the back.
He's running to the back.
Almost done.
So, how's your day going?
Wait, what were you asking?
What?
Whoever answers the question, I don't know.
Our day literally started, like, doing this.
Oh, you're running on two hours of sleep.
Good for you.
Good for you!
They're not gonna make it.
Good for you.
Yeah, you're not gonna make it.
How's the ketchup guy doing?
Oh, okay.
Ready?
Kazki's back there.
What even is the camera?
Alright, we're good?
Awesome!
Okay!
Woo!
Was that the end?
Do you want to cap it or do you want a couple more questions?
What do you think?
I'll do one more.
One special dragoon gets the last question.
One special dragoon.
One very special dragoon.
Oh, okay.
The most specialist of all dragoons.
Oh, wait, hold on.
They're doing another picture.
Sorry, they're doing one more picture.
With the lights on.
Okay, now, who's gonna be the last question?
Oh, my gosh.
It's like they're fighting, but no...
You know what?
They're not very loud.
Either side's not very loud.
I mean, that person's wearing a suit.
Oh, there's someone yelling.
Oh, no.
Okay, I gotta make a hard decision here, right?
Yeah.
Do you want me to go this way?
No.
Or this way?
The whole responsibility is on you.
I take zero blame if it's a shitty question.
Okay, each side's representative come up, and I will decide if you have a good question, and I will pick between one of you.
There, you come up.
No, make them do rock, paper, scissors.
Oh, yeah!
Okay, that's better, yeah.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Okay, okay, you got two of you, you got two of you.
Your deadline.
Wait, okay, let's go back over there, ketchup.
It's not a good question.
No, it's all right, it's all ok.
Okay, fine.
activities, it's just an instrument really.
We're doing with rock, paper, scissors.
Then they deserve to answer.
How quick is their jacket?
Where are you getting that?" Alright.
Awww!
Don't even do that!
She threw scissors.
She was ready.
Hi, Lookie!
Hello!
Okay, so I was introduced to you...
by... because you're playing Apex.
Yeah.
Because you are a FPS.
FPS.
Me too.
Yeah, yeah.
My question is...
It's okay.
You're the last question.
No pressure.
Everybody's waiting.
You're the last question to end off this entire panel, but that's okay.
We know that you are friends with a bunch of FPS players.
Yeah.
Yeah?
For Overwatch, what is your ideal team members?
Ideal team members?
Okay.
We have to put a team together.
We have to put a team together today.
Well...
Well, it's gonna be 5v5, right?
Yes.
So all four of them will be from Korea then.
Because we all know, if you're like an Overwatch, if you used to watch Overwatch League, and you used to be into Overwatch, sort of like the best players are from Korea.
So...
They are.
So, I don't really care, like, who's gonna be on the team, as long as they're all from Korea.
Because I know they're gonna clutch it for me.
To be fair, I'm not up to date with the new, the new, current hit players.
I know more about when Overwatch League used to be alive.
So I don't know...
I don't know who's still playing.
Like...
500 million dollars down the drain, I guess.
No, it's even more than that.
Like, I don't know if you guys...
Okay, for those who don't know, actual, like, football team owners invested in the Overwatch League.
So, like, that's gotta go into the billions at that point.
Like, I don't know how the fuck they're getting their money back.
But, like, at least we enjoyed it.
Like...
At least the viewers enjoyed it.
But yes, that's my answer.
As long as they're from Korea, I know they have the skills to win this for me.
Okay, guys, that's a wrap.
Thank you so much.
Don't be very much for a round of applause.
Thank you, everybody.
For Anime Revolution, like I said, if you have any gifts or letters for Mint or I, please leave it at the table.
Bye-bye, everybody.